Let's go next to why don't we go to Victor
from Indiana.
You're on the air.
Hi, David.
So I was wondering, how married are you to
the idea of social democracy or having a social
welfare programs under the framework of capitalism?
I'm I'm married.
I'm I'm married to it, but I have a prenup
and an annulment clause so I could get out
if it got ugly.
I see.
Got it.
No, I mean, sorry I cut you off.
So you're saying it sounded like you were
saying how married am I to social democracy
rather than socialism?
Sort of, I guess my main question was, do
you think socialism or even something like
communism is feasible for human society, like
maybe like a couple hundred like a thousand
years down the line?
Or do you just think that, like, capitalism
is pretty much the best we've got right now?
It's not worth talking about.
OK, so here's where I'm different from many
other commentators on this issue, lots of
commentators.
You would go to them and you would ask that
question and some people would say communism
is an inevitability.
It's just a matter of when.
And there are others on the right.
And by the way, you've got a horrible, horrible
hiss coming through.
And if we could deal with that, it would it
would be a really great thing.
Yeah, then you've got people on the right,
including Trump, I mean, Trump said it during
his state of the unions that states of the
Union addresses whatever Trump said, we will
never be a socialist country.
I am not going to pretend to tell you that
something definitely could or couldn't happen
a thousand years down the line.
If you asked anybody in the United States,
there was no United States a thousand years
ago.
If you asked people a thousand years ago in
twenty twenty one, would there be something
like the United States?
Would we have the technology we have?
Would we have the culture we have?
Nobody would have predicted this a thousand
years ago.
And so I have no idea.
I don't I think that right now everything
has led me to my current beliefs, which, as
you state, fall under the umbrella of social
democracy.
That's where I am right now.
Is it possible that things will happen in
the next two hundred or thousand years where
in a thousand years the planet, planet Earth
is a socialist planet, is a communist planet,
or there are many communist countries that
that are flourishing?
Yeah, it's how could I say no?
How could it?
So I just think that we are so bad at predicting
the future that it's certainly possible.
And if that happens, I, I don't know what
the path to it would be.
That's a fantastic answer.
Thank you so much, David.
All right, my pleasure.
Great having you on.
And that's that's an ugly history there that
was happening.
I'm glad we were able to get it, at least
briefly dealt with.